je proclame vice président du sénat
monsieur philippe dallier monsieur david
assouline
madame valérie létard monsieur jean marc
gabouty monsieur thani mohamed soilihi
madame catherine tremblay madame marie
noëlle lienemann monsieur vincent de
l'est je proclame questeur du sénat
monsieur rémy pointereau monsieur
bernard lalande monsieur vincent capo
canellas vous pouvez les applaudir
[Applaudissements]
je programme secrétaire du sénat
monsieur éric bocquet madame agnès
canayer monsieur yves daudigny madame
catherine de roche
madame jacqueline des rom ai dit
monsieur daniel dubois
madame françoise gatel monsieur joël
guerriau madame annie guillemot madame
mireille jouve monsieur guy dominique
kennel monsieur dominique de legge
monsieur victorin lurel et monsieur
michel raison
conformément à l'accord intervenu entre
les présidents de groupes politiques et
une réunion sous la présidence
madame patricia sheen âgé remplacera
madame mireille jour en qualité de
secrétaire du sénat à compter du 1er
avril 2010 9 à 0 heure je déclare le
bureau du sénat constitué communication
sera donné à monsieur le président de la
république monsieur le premier ministre
à monsieur le président de l'assemblée
nationale
je félicite chaque année membre du
bureau du sénat qui les en assurent déjà
ne manqueront pas de travail
qu'ils soient vice présidents questeurs
ou secrétaires sur les félicite
[Applaudissements]